[Musique]
hectare ou acre lequel est le plus grand
c'est l'hectare un hectare équivaut à
environ deux actes et demi lecteur
appartient au système métrique comme
kilomètres ou kilogramme depuis que le
Canada a adopté le système métrique en
1971 c'est la principale unité de
référence de surface
le Québec l'utilise mais l'usage n'est
pas courant ailleurs au pays c'est
plutôt l'acre une ancienne mesure
européenne qui est toujours en force
dans la plupart des provinces de même
qu'aux États-Unis un hectare fait 100
mètres par 100 mètres une âme 208 pieds
par 208 pieds
pour convertir une terre de milliards en
hectares il suffit de diviser par 2,4
résultat une terre albertaine où l'on
cultive du blé ou du canola sur milak et
qui vaut à une terre de 405 hectares il
existe aussi les arpents c'est très
ancienne mesure française encore parfois
utilisée à servi à délimiter les lois
agricoles sous le régime français
un harpant n'est pas une mesure de
surface c'est une mesure linéaire qui
fait 58 mètres et demi ou environ 192
pieds de long un peu moins de trois
arpents carrés font un hectare
c'est certain le commun des mortels peut
s'y perdre mais que l'on parle arpent
âcre ou hectare la plupart des
producteurs agricoles eux sont habitués
à faire la conversion et arrive à s'y
retrouver
[Musique]